you remember this passage where they
came to Jesus is said asking when the
day of judgment is and he said why you
asking me no one knows but God not
Angelus not humans that nobody knows
except Allah all the God knows so if he
is the sound what you guys say or he's a
God what most of the Christians believe
how he don't know the day yeah the
interesting thing I watched this movie
The Passion of the Christ when the Jesus
was on the cross what he was screaming
he was screaming
Allah Allah in his language called the
gut like yes and they say did you forget
about me so if you don't really know the
plans of the God and stuff like that so
I don't know what people confuse them
ourselves well yeah this one before you
even get to talking about because this
is this is what you're gonna have to be
looking into it's very simple and
straightforward if you are contemplating
the purpose of life you want to know why
you're here where you're going when you
die you're gonna have to follow the
blueprint of the Creator set now which
one which religion this person making
the claim this one that one when you
when you boil it down
you have Islam and you have Christianity
and if you're a true Christian and you
really want to follow the way of Jesus
it's gonna lead you actually to
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation Islam but now before
people even get to that worry we're even
discussing this a lot of times people
they don't even think about the purpose
of life why they're here what do you
like to tell them for me when I was a
Christian I was still fearing God person
I always want to be in a straight path
and I always have something in my heart
like I'm doing something wrong when I go
to the church at Buddhist candles to
these pictures you know what I mean this
wasn't make sense to me when I can
simply just pray straight to the God so
I pray to the God you know
with my heart and ass got to guide me
please I read the Bible and read the
Quran and the Quran when you open the
book of the Quran almost every ayat in
the Quran talking to you the God talking
to you when he guides you right over
there when you would the pure heart you
want to be guided you're gonna be guided
when you don't want to be guided you
know when you're trying to find some
folks you're not gonna be guided there's
even ayat in the Quran right says even
if they want to find something they're
not gonna find it but then I will
increase the disease in their hearts you
know so if you really want to find a
straight path just think about this look
at the Jesus lifestyle look at what he
was preaching did any the simple thing
why people eating the pork the Jesus
himself is important where he says okay
you guys can eat you tell me about the
New Testament how many people write
their book the Bible thousands and
thousands of people you know I mean the
people who write the New Testament I
don't think they even walk or talk to
the Jesus Christ or even know somebody
who knows him you know what I mean and
how this is a New Testament if this was
a written way way way back in the days
this is not new tested here in my
opinion this is just a Catholic priest
write it down on their basement I mean
it's fact that we have Bible scholars
that tell us that we don't have a copy
of a copy many people think that Matthew
wrote Matthew Luke wrote Luke these were
two disciples of Jesus but the fact is
and we're never trying to offend anyone
in any religion these are just the facts
that we don't know who Bible scholars
tell us people of course call the gospel
books Matthew Mark Luke and John
well they call the Matthew Mark Luke and
John because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean
they're they're written by people we
don't know who they were written by they
are anonymous you might not think so
because they have the title the Gospel
according to Matthew whoever put that
title on it was an editor later the
followers of Jesus were Aramaic speaking
peasants from Galilee lower-class men
who were not educated in fact Peter and
John in Acts chapter 4 verse 13 are
literally said to be illiterate they
couldn't read and write of course not
they were fishermen they didn't go to
school the
vast majority of people in the ancient
world never learned to read let alone
write and their native language was
Aramaic these books are written in Greek
by highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in Greek
composition said we don't have a copy of
a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy of
any original Bible so now imagine I give
this example imagine that you're driving
and will give two examples from this
you're driving and the police pull you
over and now they go ahead and ask for
your license so you give them a copy of
a copy of a copy of something that's not
even a copy from your license looks like
it remnants of it would they accept this
but then it goes a little bit further
what if now you had things marked off
and things were changed on that copy of
a copy of a copy of what's not even a
copy of your license so this is what we
have of today the modern day Bob that's
not that's not your fault I mean but now
people can go ahead and invest further
in that or look beyond another example I
give is imagine if me and you are
driving but you want to be the driver of
me who's driving this time okay I'm
driving so I ask you I'm driving any
slow down I'm just like and please pull
us over and they give you a ticket that
be fair but that's the whole thing and
that's what people gravitate to in Islam
that you responsibly you're for yourself
you're not staying because someone did a
sin you know Adam to descend we have
original goodness what you thought about
that being a former Christian now that
now it's someone Jesus because the whole
concept is that Jesus had to come die
for your sins and okay just logically
think about this will you sacrifice your
kid why will you do this you're all
Maude mighty god you're so powerful and
you just want to sacrifice your kid to
forgive your sins how's it makes sense
all this have no absolutely no logic to
me and I'm telling you this is a form of
Christian you know I don't offend nobody
I was a Christian I born in a very very
religious family you know every
Christmas we stay nights at the church
you know we follow
the committees and everything but you
know I find out this video on logical
because now as a father having a kids -
you know what I mean you understand this
more how like come on man but I don't
know this is just confusing all this an
Islam came God is not the author of
confusion so Islam came and a line of
messengers you see every messenger came
with the same message pay attention
chronological order it makes sense easy
to digest it doesn't have you doing a
bunch of a bunch of mental gymnastics to
make it fit
God Almighty created us and out of his
love he sent guidance and every
messenger came with the same message
worship the One God worship the Creator
not his creation and they came with a
blueprint for life the purpose of life